sleep is so important we needed to live
and when we can't sleep we're desperate
for help
but lately our fascination with sleep
feels as if it's taken on an urgency do
a quick internet search for sleep and
you'll find a slew of articles about how
to make your sleep perfect new gadgets
fancy alarm clocks stay away from Blue
Light there are lots of services
products and advice columns that tell us
we're sleeping wrong not enough not
quality sleep wrong position even worse
you might find scary messaging claiming
that if you're not sleeping right your
life is going to be shorter you're going
to get all kinds of diseases one of the
biggest worries we have about our sleep
is that we're not getting enough and
that anything less than seven hours a
night means that we're doomed to bad
Health everything from high blood
pressure to Alzheimer's disease but
there are two flaws with this kind of
messaging the first flaw is that it's
not completely accurate seven to eight
hours of sleep while recommended for
adults is just an average and while
messages have to be simplified for
health communication to the public
sometimes important nuances get lost so
yes it's true that not getting enough
sleep in the long term is associated
with health problems like cardiovascular
disease diabetes and depression but
fixating solely on seven to eight hours
ignores the fact that there's a range of
sleep that people need the duration of a
good night's sleep can be different for
different people some adults need aid
but some are just fine on six the second
flaw with this kind of Doomsday
messaging is that it can be
counterproductive especially for people
who do have trouble sleeping for
instance in 2019 it was estimated that
21 of adults in the U.S were wearing
sleep tracking devices and that number
is probably growing and I get it it's
fascinating to see how much sleep you've
gotten each night and to know what part
of your night was spent in deep sleep or
dreaming but having all of that sleep
data is causing some people to become
obsessed with it so much so that it's
leading to a condition some call
orthosomnia a preoccupation with the
constant need to achieve perfect sleep
and this condition ironically is causing
more sleep problems now Ortho somnia
might be an extreme example but the
anxiety of not getting enough sleep is
keeping some of us up at night so here's
what some experts are saying stop
fixating on the number because that can
lead to unrealistic expectations of
sleep according to Dr Colleen Carney a
psychologist and the head of the Ryerson
University sleep lab the basic questions
you should ask yourself are do I feel
reasonably well rested during the day do
I generally sleep through the night
without disturbances or if I wake do I
fall back asleep easily can I stay awake
through the day without involunt
entirely falling asleep if your answers
are yes to all three you probably don't
need to worry about your sleep and if
you're struggling with your sleep
instead of buying expensive blue light
filters or fancy sleep trackers try
talking with your doctor to make sure
there aren't any medical conditions that
need to be explored first then try
evidence-based recommendations laid out
by the American Academy of sleep
medicine what's really cool is that
there's a highly effective therapy
called cognitive behavioral therapy for
insomnia or cbti it doesn't have any
medications involved and it has a really
low failure rate